john lester knows the pirates and they
know him 13-6 career against pittsburgh
and coming off a great series against
the giants john hoping to do what his
teammates have been doing here's key
brian hayes
in the driver's seat he drives one into
center and bobbled by robles
it'll still leave hayes at first but
that hitting streak moves up to 19 games
now with a first inning single gets to
second with two out as reynolds is out
six to three and now jacob stallings
will be the battery can the pitch swing
at a chopping ground ball to short big
hop turner has it he steps and throws on
the bell and plenty of time to the side
retired jt brubaker and he'll get the
ball for the bucks today he's been our
most consistent pitcher all year
somebody that you know even as a young
guy we were looking to to be kind of
that stoppard and he hits this on the
line and oh caught out in shallow right
field by adam frazier he had to go a
long way as he ran
toward the foul line several steps onto
the outfield grass and jumped up and
took a hit away from schwarber that's
the best second baseman in the national
league so it's a runner at first and
here's josh bell that left-handed his
first a b against his former mates and
he bounces this over the mound the
shortstop is there and
kevin newman will step on second we'll
go to the second hitting and brings up
kevin newman kevin newman is a 350
career hitter against lester's
this ball's hit deep to left field if
it's fair it's way gone and kevin newman
clears the deck with a cannonball in dc
wow
long home run down the line and left
his second home run and gives the
pirates a one-nothing lead in the second
boy what a nice-looking swing from kevin
newman pirates lead one to nothing brian
reynolds switch hitting centerfielder
with one out
and cracked out toward left center
and banging them away from robus and his
home ballpark
didn't play the karum
and it's a double for reynolds now it's
jacob stallings swinging a slow ground
ball toward the left side castro cuts it
off double clutches throws to first and
still gets his man with reynolds over to
third evan's a bouncer to trey turner to
start the second
strike three call got him looking at the
knees over the outside corner evan slams
the helmet down he is dismayed with the
home plate umpire leicester's first
strikeout strands the runner at third we
go to the bottom half victor robles
leads off against jt brubacher
that ball is really hit hard out to deep
left center he's gonna one hop and go
into the red seats victor robles with
one of his hardest hit balls of the year
and he's the board to start the third
sacrifice but goes one to four robles is
now 90 feet away with the tying run
schwarber hits a line drive right field
base hit and that'll tie the game
robles jogs in from third schwarmer
drives in the game-tying run the
nationals one of the pirates one rbi
number 32 a very similar ball that he
hit in the first hit that was caught by
frazier there's trey
turner left that out over the plate
10 or a two strike hit and schwarmer is
going to try to for third he's going to
be out
he hesitated and that sealed his fate
wow what a recovery from reynolds
dropped the ball found it quickly fired
a one hopper to keep ryan hayes turner
at second the go ahead run here's soto
and there's a base hit nobody home it's
short
and there's a shortstop racing home for
the nats
2-1 washington on soto's 28th rbi
there's a two-out rbi knock for the
heart of the match lineup they pitch to
soto he delivers the go-ahead hit on the
first pitch here in the bottom of the
third well john lester finds himself
with a lead now as the national score
two and a one out single for gonzalez
here is kai tom here's the swing and a
chopper right side slowly hit harrison
has it looks at second will take the
sure out at first and so harrison gets
tom with gonzalez moving up to second
and he swings and taps one out in front
of the plate fair ball gomes is on it he
takes his time he throws to bell who has
to reach in the runner and then jump out
of the way of brubacher that's a
nimble play there by bell to avoid the
collision so lester pitches around the
single a runner left at second we go to
the fifth top of the order and frazier
against leicester
oh he overmatched one of the best
hitters in the league right there ball
under his bat high 80s for the strikeout
great front hip cutter here from john
lester
frazier with the little half swing here
two up and two down for leicester in the
fifth payoff pitch swung on hit of the
ear to center field
robles started in now back a couple of
steps and weights he makes a one-handed
grab of the side retired a one two three
top of the fifth for john lester
we go to the bottom of the fifth inning
two out and juan soto the hitter and he
grounds this ball right to the second
base bag area that's where
the shortstop newman has it and tosses
to keep ryan hayes for the force will
move now to inning number six
hit in the air to center field and
carries over the head of victor robles
who is full badly
and into second base goes the cheetah
with a double robles looks like he was
drifting in a little bit and then
went back and was over his head gives
the pirates the tying run at second and
brings in philip evans the right fielder
turner's got it nets get a
break ball did not get enough altitude
to get out of the infield
absolutely destroyed
out to short for a big first up davey
arrives on the scene once the baseball
lester gives it to him john will go five
and a third tonight 22nd appearance for
suero his record owen won stallings at
third newman at first with one out in
the sixth inning down a run eric
gonzalez the batter pitches hit in the
air to right now newman will have to get
back stallings will tag coming up with
the throw toward the plate is soda
tagging is stalling it's well off the
mark and the game is tied rowe was well
off line by soto sacrifice fly for
gonzalez ties the game at two and the
new pitcher for the pirates will be tall
right-hander clay holmes he'll work the
bottom of the seventh here's schwarber
schwarber with three home runs in his
last two games in the lead-off spot
there it goes
right field see
you
later
four home runs in his last four games
as hot as he's been all year with a long
ball
he loves that lead off spot doesn't he
3-2 nationals a one-out walk puts the
time run on base and now a battle with
newman
castro all won a pick oh what a pick
what a double play
empo had some
to start the around the horn five four
three double play
top half of the ninth inning
nationals three of the pirates too and
brad hand will try and close the door
eric gonzalez the first baseman swain in
a mess he buries the slider unreachable
for gonzalez
three good sliders by brad hand to get
the strikeout to lead off the ninth two
men away and now the left-handed the
swinging outfielder ben gamble
one hopper trey turner infielders have
been busy tonight and that'll do it
well the nats have now made it
a three and two home stand winning two
in a row